okay so
rachel
probably not dead
there was also the girl whose name i'm
now forgetting who got snatched
probably also not dead because we
haven't actually seen them physically
die we just saw them disappear rachel
fell off a cliff
she's probably still alive somehow
um
merwin definitely did
but
i think he was gonna die no matter what
i don't know
it's fine everything's fine the
generator's gone off
we're back in this room
so this is sedum's chemical weapon solo
huh
run from the [ __ ] hill that looks
like it's gonna explode
so much for eric's pioneering thermal
satellite system
eric's gonna have some pretty tough
questions to answer i also really liked
eric and now i think he sucks
the generator
let's go take a look i don't really feel
like i want to do that i feel like maybe
that's a bad idea i feel like maybe
maybe generate a good boom
okay
i need a hand here
i'm on it this is super old you guys
and
definitely flammable someone's taking a
serious dislike to this thing
look sit watch my back oh they think the
iraqis
who's this
oh
why would they turn the generator off
aren't they awesome hurry up
in a place i don't want to be in does it
look like i'm [ __ ] around
yeah it was the generator and i thought
that it was a monster
it seems odd that the
the other soldiers would be like looking
around in the dark when they also fell
around this is mailman two one actual
we're heading deeper over
acknowledged be careful in there
why
cable split
let's see where they lead to
oh all right well you you go ahead then
be my guest
he's my favorite though we'll forgive
nick
do feel like we're being lured somewhere
though i just don't know why
unless there are people who've been like
stationed down here for a long time or
something [ __ ]
watch your step
there's a drip wire
that's pretty calculated but it's also
just like they put the grenade
duct tape simple enough
counter explosion
no
just need to cut the trigger
okay
he could have been wrong about that
i wonder if somebody would have just
straight up died there if i had
got to be the guy who shot at eric
[ __ ] hunting us
if i had [ __ ] that up dropkick this is
mailman two one actual do you copy over
dropkick receiving how's it going out
there cold jack
your friend sprung an ied on us we're
good you'll want to keep your eyes open
in case she's left any more love notes
over i guess if it's just one dude
in theory more of them should have
fallen down too but
shame you warned him about the trip why
harsh
um if it's just one dude
then sure you'd be wanting to do stuff
like that right
we have assembled our team top of my
list was unintelligible crow the bulldog
of omaha beach we found him in cairo
brawling for money in 11 teen drinking
club croy recommended and in haifa we
picked up my assistant the always
inquisitive arlene giorno
insisted on the presence of her own
advisor ellis van hooten
an archaeolog an archaeologist i know
from
our team complete we shall head to
lebanon from there by train to
october the 21st
1946 randolph sounds kind of cute crow
was the first to break into the tomb
an honor he shared with bessie that
damned a machine gun of his
it was a beast of a weapon
but it seemed to comfort the fella
during the digging
this place has lain undisturbed for
centuries
it is not the tomb of alexander the
great
but a temple of an even older god king
the acadian despot
naram sin
hmm
from the start i'm mistaken
but lady bradshaw still declares it to
find for the ages
a discovery that will write our names in
the annals of history the anals of
history
wow
i have no reason to doubt her
i do like the way they're telling this
backstory i think it's pretty neat i'm
i'm interested
in what happened to them um because
we're getting like so many different
periods of time
okay that seems like a good one you can
stab somebody stake somebody are there
vampires down here as well
oh no
i don't love that
okay
did i look at this stuff
a59 again my favorite film studio that's
a star map
i mean this is just like archaeological
stuff right
what's this
seems fine
he could be waiting for us down there
listen
what seems that
is your life shall we
oh
what no it's not awesome you heard him
just now it can't be that is definitely
him joey seemed pretty dead to me
[ __ ] place jason
i'm telling you i saw him die
all due respect buddy you're not your
usual self
can't know for sure
i'm with him though i really thought
that dude was dead but it's a trap we
don't know that
we don't leave men behind
semper fi
sacrifice
oh my god that [ __ ] statue
out we heard joey through the tunnel
jesus staring at
gonna rescue him
let me remind you that i make the
decisions i'll lead the way i trust you
most of the time but then that whole
situation with rachel now you just seem
like a cuck and i don't respect you
anymore
say nothing let him do whatever he wants
not without me you don't
eric i really was on your team i was so
pro eric
how'd the mighty have fallen
oh i forgot about salim that's right
oh no
oh no
i don't feel great about that
oh cool a wallet never mind who cares
about this creepy hand
money
you okay there buddy
what's happening there i've got a lot of
visual glitchy business going on here
huh
no okay
oh god i'm nervous
i'm
not feeling good about grabbing this
plank if that's what it wants me to do
no
oh i hate that
um where are we supposed to go boss man
what's the plan
oh my god
[Music]
anywhere else that i can go
oh gosh
okay
unsure maybe i do have to go interact
with creepy hand
oh a noise
okay
i was worried she'd say that
okay
[Music]
yeah
yep
we don't love that
[Music]
oh bud
i don't know that oh [ __ ]
oh you're just going deeper i don't know
if i could back out but i am curious
oh
thanks
i should have backed out shouldn't i i
should have i don't i didn't need to do
that i didn't need to i was also curious
what did i think was gonna happen
the fact that they can fly really
cuts the poles
nice
okay buddy i like you and i i want you
to be okay
oh maybe they want like the sun
maybe they were like the light yeah
nice
well now i just sort of back at square
one though whereas when we were in the
sun we
were like a little bit better off
maybe you can kill it
oh this is the fake one
um
i did it
i was worried i staked the wrong part of
it because i didn't see it go red
okay
that's a good endo
hello again
oh they heard him
that makes sense
these don't look like the americans
who are these guys
we don't have fancy hats and mosques
it's always clicking sounds it's always
50
oh god
i don't think these are people i know
that right
i don't know who these dudes are
okay
oh nice
boots what could go wrong
heading away from the sunlight that we
just rendered um as super useful
what could go wrong
oh my god that's the darkest thing i've
ever seen
oh god
i hate this oh okay
i will take whatever you are thank you
jesus
this is probably a reference to the
eclipse
yeah i should be putting
how am i even supposed to know where to
go
okay this way
is that back the way i came
going over here
i'm just hoping this is a new direction
and not a back track
i think it's a backtrack
all right
back into pua
goddamn darkness
just a little bit tense it's fine it's
fine everybody's doing fine
that's the thing
okay
i don't even know how i made it through
that i can't see [ __ ]
there's sunlight right there
[Music]
oh so then we actually don't know what
these dudes heard
[Music]
yeah they don't have gas masks so it
wasn't them
check your corners
still here joey
hmm
this is mailman two one actual joey do
you hear me helicopter you gotta stop
jason with your how copies and you who
wants it
i don't think it's gonna help
oh is joey's hat
you were with lance corporal gomez would
probably be a funny difficult hat what
actually happened to
him he died
whatever's out there now
sure [ __ ] and joey
well and that all these things are often
difficult to judge what's that supposed
to mean you could've been mistaken
sergeant that's true
if you say so colonel
we just have to hope he's still alive
i'm just trying to play the characters
like kind of what i think that
i'm sorry they based on their contacts
with the other characters would do is
that
so kolchak told me you people called her
the queen [ __ ] no by me
i knew it better than that oh
did ya
okay
check your weapons don't leave anything
to change
i feel like i should be looking around
what is this
[Music]
is that blood
eric
what did you think something really
[ __ ] nasty went down here
oh
what
what
ah
i hate you more every day what it what
else would it be in this abandoned
[ __ ]
shrine
other than blood
you nincompoop i want to go investigate
whatever that other light thing was
before going any further but i'm just
worried i'm going to get locked up from
somewhere because it's like this seems
like the right way to me
i get that a lot fisher's like this back
at the temple nice a self names guesses
the quakes open them up
let's just keep going okay
i guess were they quakes i didn't
identify them as quakes i thought that
they were um
this [ __ ] place there was a sinkhole
or something
the catacombs beneath the temple are
heaped with unintelligible a lion has
worked sacrificial digs in el castillo
but even she hasn't seen unintelligible
unintelligible killed thousands in the
name of their gods unintel intelligible
in charnel pits as though the slaughter
unintelligible
what plague or cataclysm demanded such a
price so much unintelligible whatever
happened here millennia ago is a
unintelligible
um
i feel like my reading is really good
they're fine down there keep messing
words up oh probably should i get
excited about this i'm gonna find them
helpful
okay
maybe we can be friends with him i would
love to
it's tough when you can't communicate
though
who is that
he's close this is so [ __ ] up be quiet
we're walking into a trap
is everybody with me okay
uh oh oh oh oh government
what was that even supposed to be
oh god
i'm shook
what is it it wasn't was that a person
was that a vampire
oh god
did i
was that literally all there was to see
you
i guess so
i don't need to tell you how to do your
job but okay you're gonna anyway okay
check your weapons check ammunition and
check again
pay attention to details oh this is
where we came from recycle back
around you may not be alone that's what
i think i jumped through at least maybe
not this is perfect for an ambush let's
keep it slow and tight
no double time joey needs us now we
gotta hurry
oh maybe that joke is him
it does sound like an american ah
[ __ ]
it's too dangerous man he's right
advance with cars he gotta go slow but
he might die because of that which is
obama but i just feel like
listen to the the leader even though i
think eric's a big dummy
we would have got shot son
[Music]
[ __ ]
is just the one guy there's three of us
i feel like we'll probably be okay
to be fair
i don't know how war works
i'm familiar with it
also
he's gonna say maybe throwing a grenade
in here is like
a bit of a self-sabotage my friend
this is mailman three two mailman two
one actual come in lieutenant over
this is mailman three two mailman two
one actual come in lieutenant over
mailman three to dropkick colonel are
you there over
i really don't want nick to die
i don't feel good about this at all
jeez
oh the camera angles
oh god why is your head so big
oh this is so nerve-wracking
my stomach is
not having a great time
oh we know this we are nervous
you're okay buddy
it's that's not like a noise that noise
is bad
[Music]
okay
[Music]
i like that design a lot i think they're
really cool looking
is that no that's one of them
it's not joey do exactly what they say i
swear to god i'll feed you to that thing
[Music]
[Applause]
seen their weakness
they burn in sunlight
like any living being they can be killed
let's take through the heart
okay your bullets will only slow them
down
even a truck falling on them just makes
them
he does literally experience that yeah
he's right we do this together okay
what what's up with the lighting there
you can kill it boss man has orange
eyelashes
i will do the rest okay
i'm ready let's do it
i wonder who made him uh
surrender in the
premonition then
[Music]
it's weird how like when there's quiet
moments in games that i also feel like i
need to be quiet you gonna tell me that
didn't make a bunch of slappy scrapy
[ __ ] noises
come on now
[Applause]
where's the light they're trying to
alert to behind it it's kind of in the
light
is it not
oh god
i guess not
that looks like sunlight that's a harsh
shadow that could just be
something else though i guess
[Applause]
huh
visual that was interesting
i really don't want to kill you nick i
really want you to live like badly want
you to live i think you really
seem really nice
i like your ginger eyelashes i think
they're a positive
and you have strangely blonde
eyebrows
okay what do you want me to do
just just shoot it's the right answer
how many of them are there though
like
[Music]
am i really are we prepared for this
because
i've seen ugly in my life
but never that ugly we gotta sneak
around some of them
what the [ __ ] are we up against yeah
those things are everywhere yeah
never before have i ever seen anything
so vicious
what do you think those things are
you know what i i don't know i didn't
think to ask how about you
i don't know what they ought
i shouldn't be here
i should be home
with my son
nah i hear you family's
everything hey i should have never come
here when you're in this kind of
situation you just cut right to the
chase huh
it's his birthday today
oh man
you really shouldn't be here
how
old enough to think he's a man
he's only still a boy
he just turned 18. stealing watches
big day
big day
it is a big day let me tell you is it a
big day in america best present you can
give him
getting out of here make sure
you get home today
yeah 18's is a huge deal in australia
because that's one you can drink 21 kind
of doesn't mean anything the only thing
keeping me going would be odd if 18 were
a big deal in the us
but i also don't know what the rules are
for most other countries i guess you
should at least know my name nikkei
sergeant ah
salimos man
lieutenant i'm happy about this i feel
good about this
ah
this is mailman two an actual mailman
three how copy over hey solid coffee lt
i see you're like keep moving forward
i'm just ahead over i'm coming to get
you uh i'm gonna shoot him
no
no no that won't happen surely don't
um
yeah
fine cover go
go
ah like i debated that because of the
premonition right because he put his
hands up but then maybe he walks out
with his hands up
my god
you're right
yeah eric what the hell is dick bag
makes your ain't as pucker don't it
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's exactly without
thinking
no
sergeant k
you all right
uh [ __ ]
ah like i want to tell them i'm not good
but this place is a bust right whatever
the hell happened to joey he's gone and
there [ __ ] knows how many of those
things out there i want to tell them
that he said temple and regroup but i
think that's the best plan i heard all
day
oh [ __ ]
maybe it's that
nick would have gotten in trouble for
colluding
and that intense thing made it seem like
[ __ ] i'm ready to [ __ ] that up
because it came with the premonition he
put his hands up did i just doom him ah
ah
these games are stressful as hell dude
but all of my three alive boys are at
least together right now
we still don't know about rachel or the
other girl and i guess that's a
confirmation that joey is dead even
though i always thought he was dead
anyway so there's no real update
is that yours or was that in here
already
get it together
oh
well you just you think you just killed
the love of your life so
you're doing quite well all things
considered
[Music]
my name is lieutenant colonel eric king
of the united states air force
i'm a chief nuclear engineer of the iraq
survey group passed with locating hidden
chemical weapons
our mission
has uncovered something
unexpected
and we'll now begin an autopsy of an
unidentified life form wow okay
hmm you making youtube videos
me too
what's up
why did you do that
you guys the last one
should at least slow them down need to
stop blowing things up this place is
about the cameras not safe oh that's why
they set them up
that's smart
but also
structural integrity of this
[ __ ] tomb
what is wrong with all of you
maybe i take it back maybe you do
deserve to die
we should reset that drip wire give me a
hand
we've been in some [ __ ] up situations
before oh never as [ __ ] as this
if i got to fight these things
there's no one else i would want by my
side
it's nice
you know i always got your back buddy
not really been looking at the
at the relationships very much
heroic dutiful confident pragmatic
responsible
hmm
i know there is but not in the way that
i want to play it
okay
that was ominous
exceptionally pointed
this is something else
you think
we know how many places like this we've
bombed without a second thought
these relics are better off than dust
well this one yes
what's your problem
these people didn't ask for this war it
was a quick turn
what would he do
he'd probably no let's go curious why
are you defending the enemy sergeant
you and me both know they're not all our
enemies [ __ ] jason
it's about the girl at the checkpoint
[ __ ] nick how many times
we thought she had a bomb
it was just a bag of groceries
we [ __ ] up
yeesh
it is kind of a tough thing with these
games like i feel like sometimes as a
matter of fact it is the character
changes sort of come out on an om isn't
it getting under yours
i saw what you did to that shepherd
earlier and your tough guy act isn't
ever going to make that [ __ ] right
mailman 21 actual this is dropkick
request update over
doing actual receiving cameras are green
and the holes have been demolished over
good work lieutenant
tweet through the eastern corridor and
be on your guard
why are they acting like over now
soldiers are priority or maybe they're
not maybe that was all put in place for
the monsters who are probably not gonna
recognize a tripwire
that approximation the creature is
eight feet tall
bipedal wing
wing webbing appears to be affixed to
its forelimbs into the
digits of its hands
it's a bat
it's a little larger to be
smothered in some sort of
inspiration nice
underneath it is
deceased almost
what does that mean
creature is starting to rapidly
decompose in death
dropkick this is mailman 21 actual
approaching eastern passage over
i see you
christ these doors took a hammer and
those things must have come through here
in force
whoever man that weapon took a stand and
held them off
before they got massacred from behind
these creatures aren't dumb they're
predators
that's your bottom dollar if they came
this way before
they could come again
yeah
not as wise as your delivery made it
sounds logical if anything yes they
could also come through the same doorway
more than once
you're not wrong my friend you are not
wrong
no we haven't explored it before let's
do it
i do feel like we should be trying to
get out with like a little bit more
haste
but um
what do i know
never been trapped in an underground
tomb ooh that
that depth it's very cool
okay
that's a body
you've been dead
unintelligible stank of death and was
littered with unintelligible enough to
be covered in flies crow thinks
unintelligible down here after rubbing
them i pity those hapless wanderers they
fear they must have felt unintelligible
this was not what he wanted to show us
i see it's multiple words that they have
unintelligible
like that seems like it says
mary tumbled
on
there something
i don't know
i don't think unintelligible when mary
asked what it was bradshaw nodded to
crow who broke open the dynamite she
said she intended to find out
blowing a hole through the rock face
we found a gateway to a strange world
below
a phosphorescence emanated from beneath
casting its eldritch light over us all
lady bradshaw was insistent that we
descend further
perhaps mary is right
and bradshaw is becoming reckless and
uncontrollable
but i can't stop thinking about what's
down there
i am now working with crow and pullman
to set up a winch and elevator to
descend into the shaft
what mysteries lie below i wonder
undisturbed mostly just like spooky
vampire dudes like they're super [ __ ]
up and also some [ __ ] bag named eric
what's that
don't worry about it because they found
something weird down here
shocking truly i know [ __ ] this is a lot
of bones actually oh hang on i remember
this from the
from the this is from like the prologue
bit right
what the [ __ ] man
why on earth did you do that you weird
dude
was that necessary
okay jason
i like you because nick likes you and i
trust nick with my life
but damn
more crap would you find it
nothing that's going to get us out of
here it's cool
right now i couldn't give a crap if it
was the crown jews of england
did nick just take that nice nice my man
curator of fine arts nick
perfect
this looks like a good choke point any
of those freaks coming up from below
sure to pass through here set some
chargers
yeah
yeah rigged these pillars for maximum
coverage yeah that's one more likely to
see the triple wires though
you think those things can tell a
difference
we shouldn't underestimate them we mine
the sides i'd be surprised if they know
what a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
let's go for maximum coverage wire up
the middle i just don't feel like they'd
know let's do it we gotta make each one
count
even though
i was the one saying i feel like we
maybe need to chill on the explosion
with the structural integrity of this
building i just feel like
you know we're in it now so hear your
brain taken away
what is it
i made a friend should have given her a
second warning
[ __ ] man i wish i hadn't asked i'm
through talking about this
yeah what's left to say
you know that checkpoint was a prime
target for suicide bombers we had to act
in the moment we had to make a call
it was the wrong call
why is it that no one ever tells it
straight
everyone just makes a [ __ ] to get by
that's why we're in the sandbox in the
first place right
[Music]
i just want the truth jason
shooting that woman mess with my head
you seriously gonna tell me it didn't
mess with yours man uh i don't know
how to answer this
he would say let it go i think those
demons down there will kill you but the
demons in here will eat you from the
inside out
you gotta let it go man i just feel like
that's what jason would say ah
so that's you all moved on yes i have i
sure as hell have
nah
i know you too good
when you lie you always say things twice
first one to see how it floats second
one
to nail it down
nikki
come on you guys i think that maybe we
need to get out of here
also wait did i not choose the tripwires
did i accidentally choose
are you serious
i may have chosen the wrong explosion
and i thought no okay
okay cool it's armed
let me answer that for me real quick
dropkick this is mailman two and actual
we're at a stairwell leading down into a
maze please advise over
acknowledged
pull back now and secure the perimeter
drop kick out
mount a camera here
let's head back
sounds good to me
[Music]
oh god i thought she'd be alive hey rach
hey
i'm super sorry about doing this to you
how are you alive
you should be super dead
you landed in a
pool of blood or is that okay that is
not her own blood
oh my god
[Music]
oh that's nasty
eric oh that's the eggs eric
where are you
what does that much blood smell like i
wonder
just like
iron
like what is a giant pool of blood smell
like i wonder what video games smell
like quite often oh pixels hello
what is this what is this what is this
oh god oh god oh god oh god
girl we gotta be we gotta be
just real
quiet down here
oh no it can't be anything good
it's fish
you blood fish you know they
they love it down here
it's super chill
okay
there is it there you go
there you go
okay
yeah cool helmet very nice
for your uh cosplay
great
okay
it is
there
i'm gonna keep going this way
i think
which does make me feel like i'm missing
stuff but
staying alive
okay
is that an interactive shiny thing no
okay
rude
just trying to get away from this
[ __ ] fish down here dude
just trying to
exit the aquarium
not
great about it
that's a bone
what is
the plan with the bone oh smart okay
hey i have been dead well before her
frankly i don't really still buy that
she's alive at all
i think this is maybe um this is heaven
she's a big fan of blood
she's definitely dead and this is her
ideal afterlife
and the fish is god
fish is gone
is that baby maybe
these guys just like swimming
really like a full grown one he just
likes a nice swim
hey
i do too i guess i wonder if maybe
aliens look at us that way
like i just sometimes i just sit in a
pool for an hour i love pools
especially when i'm like hungover
maybe aliens are looking down on me
and they're just like even even the the
full-size one
just sits in a tub of liquid
for an hour
what the hell is that light
great question
is it that light you're referring to the
green what is that
nothing okay
i don't think she's referring to this
light
being that it's a collectible
and not a real light
oh
nice
my chemical romance
album mod
saliva we have collected and bottled the
black why did i say saliva
it just says saliva
am i okay
um present on the more of the creature
extracted from the cocoon
i and the others who smelt the substance
have experienced heart palpitations
jesus and a heightened sense of fear
some have reported odd visual effects
such as a change to colors we have
attempted to secure additional samples
of the saliva from the site where m was
attacked the smell was so overpowering
that respirators were used to collect
the samples we recommend the use of moss
at all times when handling samples to
avoid becoming affected sensations
similar to experience with mushrooms
sil-silocubin is that a real thing
um
that's interesting that explains the gas
marks guys were they already here for
some purpose i wonder
they're not a part of either of these
teams
um i don't know
but
that would be
why they felt like they needed full gas
masks down here but that means they're
like pretty current unless they're a
hallucination ugh
that is one thing that like can kind of
drive me nuts about these games
dude can you leave me alone please
is
when they're just like and then it was
all hallucinations
i prefer if it wasn't
i'm already pretty scared
especially this is probably terrifying
for a lot of people i know a lot of
people are really scared of like dark
water i never have been
but uh
oh yeah she hasn't seen the machine
okay
that's cool
there's the light
that's good that's cool
i'm just trying to keep you alive from
both
she's alive too
cool okay i didn't expect that much
okay great
that's a good creature it has powerful
claws and fangs formed from hardened
and identifiable tissue it could be bone
could just be bone two of the incisors
appear grossly malformed and discolored
gosh you don't have to talk about me
like i'm not right
here membrane surrounding the specimen
seems to originate from its mouth
blood is like nothing i've seen
i'll now perform you'll be sweep to
further inspect the fluids
luminol
that was that premonition
hell yeah
get
those is that you
didn't have the option to bring those or
not
[Music]
very glad we have that though
oh i feel like i thought i saw a zombie
kind of thing before
zombies as well
surely though right
gonna go off again
son of a
looks like a line out
maybe we can get the radio working and
send a signal out it's worth a shot
a long shot
well we don't even know if there's a
working transmitter on the surface
those wires gotta go somewhere though
you think they still work
looks to me that they just snagged up
don't feel much like climbing out there
what is zombies
what
what the [ __ ] joey
that's joey
what
[ __ ] joey it's me
oh my god
what
[Laughter]
okay
little double jump all right buddy yeah
cool ones
[Laughter]
damn it corporal gomez
i've got just a bit of paint on you
what is this cosplay
oh my god that's very silly
that is very silly
they just call them comments
oh
okay so i guess
if you get bitten it is a real vampire
situation
and that's what you become is what that
means
[Laughter]
oh wow
that's not safe wonder if i could have
saved him though i wonder if i made a
mistake and it would have been
i could have joey with me for longer i
don't know because that seems pretty
scripted
[Music]
you look ridiculous
yeah i love it okay
[Music]
i didn't know that you could fight
yeah me either
what was that thing
i don't know
whatever it is it's not alone
just a little bit of blood
one of those things got its dirty hands
on me dragging me down here left me for
dead
didn't eat of it [ __ ] doesn't even start
to cut it
i'm lucky to have gotten away you're
talking to a scientist there's no such
thing as luck you should be thankful i
was there to help she's hot
um
i'm really grateful
thank you
semper fi
we got to find out i'm sure i'm playing
rachel nicer than i should be so this is
where you've been also is it really like
an alana pace gameplay
they can't hear you talking are we just
not worried about that anymore or
no
okay
looks painful
yeah
it
the fact that you can even walk honey
it's a video game it's fine it's fine
thanks clarice
damn that [ __ ] lighting looks so good
there
i saw those same symbols in the
shepherd's heads those people must have
been in the valley a long time
oh she's gonna turn i kept wondering if
she looked sort of gray
because she was
dying there's a way or if it was just
weird lighting
there's no way we're making it
yeah she's gonna turn into a
a gomez
it's barely climbable
we can make it together how did i know
you were gonna say it's so silly
i met eric in climbing class i can get
us out of here
you know what i'm saying
was it to make noise was that
a foot with a sandal on it
my god
not
sandals the worst
she's for sure gonna sprout horns like
any minute now
yeah just need a minute
and i can't wait
just took a twist until it does took a
turn
i had a twist i just didn't expect it
thanks rachel you ever think about going
into motivational speaking you do that
seriously though are you okay
that's gotta be about the dumbest
question i have ever been asked
give me the silent treatment huh
ah focus on survival i think right now
we should just focus on survival
it's no wonder they call you the queen
[ __ ]
sad thing is you don't even see it
it wasn't see what exactly a harsh thing
to say you don't let anyone in it's like
there's a wall around you not not even a
wall a
mountain tell me rachel
is there even a real person behind
listen clarice
um
i realize i'm covering the options is
playful not easy being queen [ __ ]
uh
i'm gonna go with the playful option
actually it's not easy being queen [ __ ]
you think i got where i am with a soft
word and a warm smile
um my guess is she's like because she's
dying she's just being old i'm thinking
langley types grew up on easy street
easy street
i had to graft to get here
you think it bothers me what people call
me
i wear that [ __ ] like a badge of [ __ ]
honor
they have no idea of the shithill i've
climbed just to get to where i am right
now
yeah
and where is that exactly in a tim
with a dead [ __ ]
looks like another [ __ ] hill if i'm
truly honest with myself
it's not looking great
you and i
we're not so different
you know both doing what needed to be
done to get to where we wanted to be
no shame in that
no shame
yeah
at least you'll get wings though i
presume
you're making so much noise
can you like turn slash die
tiny
what did that thing do to you please
please don't leave me down here alone
just kill her
um but don't come any closer
don't come any closer
what's happening to me
i
please stay with me i mean i would
do it but i [ __ ] out um
okay
i won't leave you
i promise but we should also shoot her
in the face you have to tell me
what did that thing do to you
it's something she would know bitter
do we have nasty nasty sex there's
medication up there
it may help you but we need to know
about i don't know i don't know what i
don't know about this plan love
what medication
what what
and where you haven't been here before
what
i have questions
give me your hand
oh god
what do you got like some antibiotics
that's just gonna stop it
some zomba way
we're on the wrong side of the chasm
we'll never make it oh my god she looks
terrible
still hot
all right go we have to swing over
go without her that rope won't hold
go
bring the medication whatever the [ __ ]
it is
do you really believe those medicines
will help me
no
keep it together anyway though
keep it together curry's oh i didn't say
yeah i didn't lie to her you didn't
answer my question
where i see it
it's your only hope
we can do this no you can't no no no no
no no that's not true she's definitely
going to die
i didn't consent to that latter half of
the conversation she's [ __ ] dead as
[ __ ] dude
don't send it back
she looks like a zombie
oh god
it's his face is getting all like
wrinkly
[Music]
oh
[ __ ]
i'm gonna help her and i'm gonna hope
that i can put her down
because
logically
rachel doesn't actually know what's
going to happen to her
you would not assume
zombie vampire you wouldn't just jump to
that
she wouldn't know
that answer your question
we need to get you to the team oh god
okay
this is a lot
soothing
why is he by himself wasn't he with eric
and jason
i'm not seeing anything come up but i
can hear them
sounds like they're having way more fun
down there and then we are up here over
long as they keep the party to
themselves i'm happy
we got nothing on the camera shin shot
over
eyes
alive oh
that's a next step
i hope that doesn't happen to you buddy
hope you're okay
oh man
i don't know what my actual objective is
right now though
i'm just gonna look at it all right
that's fine
fake what boob ah dick site
clapper [ __ ]
they set up a fake dick site to draw off
grave robbers
they knew whatever was down here it was
pretty special
huh
um what's the objective right now patrol
the perimeter okay all clear for now
if they hit us my best hunch is it'll be
from the chasm if
you feeling optimistic lieutenant
we're facing an enemy we know zero about
you know they don't like uv
and their
i don't know how long those doors can
hold them back
radio is our best shot let me fix it up
pull in the cavalry
even [ __ ] up a bit
if there is a transmitter up there it's
gonna have a limited range
damn it
if eric had allowed close air support
those birds could have picked up the
single trust uprise to [ __ ] you in the
ass mm-hmm
well good news i already found the radio
i've already scoped it out
don't worry about it i got you
i'm gonna need a hand to get this up and
running
where did erica
that thing looks like it was sabotage
answering my questions straight away how
would they do that
we got to work with what we have
pull back if anything moves out here
it's safer inside
thank you
good job sergeant yeah but
what who are we going to contact
the iraqi military like what is the plan
those things will kill you sergeant
yeah like smoking is the biggest threat
to my life right now
what the [ __ ] did i need a lighter
what's good it's nothing uh oh
[Music]
rachel how's your lighter that means
you're [ __ ]
dead giveaway
it's just a ghost signal even without a
transmitter a radio picks up a faint
signal it's just ghosts man
so fix that transmitter if we can
establish a signal and contact centcom
then we're one step closer to home
i'll know man i'm no technician if
merwin was here though
he could fix it no [ __ ] well you did
accidentally murder him
which i guess maybe i did maybe i
shouldn't put all the blame on you for
that one i had
a pretty significant hand in that
i'm really sorry about that
omar are you being
do they both know about
oh he
salim obviously does know about the bad
guys but does
does the other guy
about the vacuums
there are just way bigger [ __ ] things
to worry about yeah
[Laughter]
very satisfying actually
nah dude it's [ __ ] up down here
but maybe he gets shot first and then
you surrender
and again
right
how did the cameras not catch them
yes they didn't set them up
[Applause]
oh no
i mean yeah they can fly
working now
i need more time
[Music]
colonel get back inside the temple i'm
staying here i need you on the cameras
in case you get flanked
you got me all being playing i said i
got this go
okay
[Applause]
are you gonna run towards
enemy soldier
ah
yep
oh geez
[ __ ] idiot man
absolute idiot
also eric yeah he's fine
don't do it
don't
move
he has the higher ground
don't
don't even think about it
i feel like i'm really just watching
this part surely it's going to come up
oh my god
okay
[Applause]
i would be interested to see what people
have actual military training on on the
experience think of this
disagreed is accurate
i definitely feel like the way that they
treat each other in terms of like
ranking and [ __ ]
wouldn't be
they're just like being rude to each
other no matter what
which doesn't seem right to me
i do like that the game also gives you a
heads up on what kind of qt's you're
gonna have that's pretty neat
but eric
oh no
what is wrong with you stay still
oh you guys really gotta [ __ ] chill
out with
that oh there rabbit
i
pretty well aimed for the head there
come on now
i really wanted him to die
that's a shame
now i like screwed out here huh push
forward into the temple move
oh jeez
put your shoulder into it
all right
let's go see the iraqis
if they got any sense they'll stay back
[ __ ] is about to get real in here
wait
rachel
rachel
oh my god she's just so deadly
you're alive
have any doubt maureen
oh god okay
everybody need to watch out for her so
those things take you
that's upsetting
where's eric
you can't do that he didn't he doesn't
even know you
i can't be dude that that's not fair i
know a tim rich
i know
you better step off before i start
swinging
colonel or no colonel
don't nick i would go for nick in the
fight here
oh god um [ __ ]
i don't i tried waiting eric
i really did i'm sorry
loyal
you held on
i didn't
okay sprout holes
the [ __ ] is happening to her she's
infected
she's turning into one of those things
why'd you bring her here i need our help
she's gonna be on her erica's you
shouldn't be here
we gotta wait
um
you answer to my orders
ah [ __ ] uh
just step aside
somebody please kill her
[Music]
wait but could we watch out grow the
horns first because that would be that
would be cool
yes
hold her kill her
like go with me for the greater good
the greater good
she's not even herself anymore you're
killing some other [ __ ] yes good okay
great yes
i'm sorry
usually i would be against the hot girl
dying
yeah you can't murder the date exactly
if you saw what happened to joey you'd
understand
hmm
we're [ __ ] around get your [ __ ]
together
all right go back to the main temple
are we just gonna like run into
iraqis though because he still hasn't
seen any and i feel like she's gonna
[ __ ] get back up anyway
she's totally just gonna get back up
she's gonna be fine
what was i saying ew
what was that
oh god
we can't lose the generator we're blind
without it
these doors are
causing them a lot of problems
also that generator is
a thousand years old
they're inside already can't get any
more in don't care what they're invited
hold the gate i'll get the generator
running
[ __ ] that's all we need
is this place mind it's not mind enough
it is mined though
what
what
what oh he's telling me that i've
swapped my playing ass maybe i don't
know what just happened all these things
i was too busy doing the hand thing
we need that generator wait but they did
say the the mention of the
hallucinogenics i wonder if like the the
dead body of it was getting the most
problems as well maybe
the uv does work very well
that does nothing
a very favorable position oh [ __ ]
they're coming through [ __ ] things
are worse than cigarettes well maybe if
he shoots holes then we use the uv right
why is this happening again
okay
okay hey
hi
oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] you gotta be messy with me oops
i made a big bad there i did a big bad
mistake on that one the uv light i think
now it's about the time we bug out
any objections
grab it grab the uv light grab it grab
it did it break why are you not using it
i guess technically when they're going
on fire i would like the door they're
breaking through the perimeter you got
any bright ideas it has the time
come on
there's got to be something
wait yes
okay we can make for the catacombs we
need to go down
town in case you missed it that ain't
the way out it's either that or we die
where we stand let's go down everyone
move to the east gate nothing wrong with
going down sometimes when in doubt
you be like dude come on
oh [ __ ] uh
uh i'm gonna go with retreat
why didn't you retreat as well dude i
didn't think that would make you die
i did that because i told that you would
also retreat
watch out for your own [ __ ] tripods
watch out for your own tripwires
oh my god i'm so panicked
um
oh [ __ ] uh uh uh stick the walls
stick to the wall
right
because i put them on the
middle right yeah
you think that was the right call oh my
god
okay
what medicine is she talking about was
she just talking about getting back to
that main chamber
i didn't think your [ __ ] would
know what to do about it
i didn't think
you'd be like oh that's military grade
wire right there
they've got c4 on the pillars
oh make sure you're careful
maybe we could hop over it
i didn't think so
listen
can you hear them
blast must have cut us off
we should keep moving
that was spicy that was a lot of tension
there
what happened
ah dude
dude you just you dude
hello again
my friend is not happy yeah i can see
that
what happened
your friend's a little too jumpy for my
liking it's making me nervous
lowering your weapon might help
alleviate some of the tension
faker
no neither are you dude that's what i
was thinking you guys are like [ __ ]
way out numbered
make a move i [ __ ] dare you
i feel like our uniforms are getting in
the way of what could be a beautiful
relationship
that's abba shut up
i say we drill these sorry looking
[ __ ] what'd you think colonel
at least this time it won't be in the
back
make the call colonel
oh god
tie them up
they show resistance shoot them that
seems okay drop your weapons not killing
them
i am warning you
don't test us
sam
we must get this door open
why are you standing there help
don't even think about it [ __ ] jason the
enemy of our enemy is our friend
move come on man
that worked
out damn it
help them i'll cover the corridor
[ __ ]
move
i just don't trust this guy you know i
don't trust him
but they are
outnumbered okay
a lot of dead people down here we get it
we get it we'll get it
nice this looks like the worst place in
the goddamn world
does it
you just shot your friend in the head
we've been through some [ __ ] man oh
oh no
i was looking for a point to stop
playing but this has been non-stop
action this whole time
i feel like
[Applause]
get your [ __ ] uv out man
[Music]
that's the skeleton
did he break the light what the [ __ ] are
you doing man
do you not realize
i guess
it's the iraqi that
knows
oh
yeah i'm wondering maybe eric didn't
realize the uv thing
freezing isn't what i would have
expected oh
is this even a zombie or is this just a
man no that's not
[Applause]
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
i took a risk man i took a risk
uh
[Music]
oh my god
roman's gonna get his neck stamp
okay
i don't know what i thought
i thought
yeah you guys are pretty much [ __ ] in
here
my logic is she didn't know so she was
gone up for sure so we can keep them
both alive and we can make allegiances
yeah eric
help
about [ __ ] time
thanks [ __ ]
jesus
i'm trying i feel like i'm like watching
my children and just trying to keep them
all alive
i might have just killed her
yes
yes yes yes grab it yes yes yes yes yes
because i mean the fact that eric did
that to save nick too
we're very happy about that finally
someone's using [ __ ] uv light
this dude does not give a [ __ ]
oh my god
what's it waiting for
[ __ ]
yes
you just abandoning everybody now eric
okay so nick's still in that room
i guess he's still alive
rachel's gonna slowly be turning
i don't think she's dead yet
and i'm fine with it
oh man that was a lot
geez
i feel like we should end it here
but i just need i just need it to pause
so it'll save
just anywhere
because i don't think i can
no i can't
who is that
okay jason's okay
i'm pretty sure nick's okay eric's okay
to mess with the marine saleem's okay
not sure about rachel but pretty sure
she's also okay
catacombs usually do have
entrances and exits right
confront
i come in peace
don't you [ __ ] move
you alone
anyone else make it
it all happened too fast
i think it's just you and me
just you and me huh well that's just
[ __ ] great
i mean you know
i don't mean you any harm
i swear
no [ __ ] i'm the one holding the gun
i just wanted to get back first birthday
says the american with a gun
um we can be allies if not friends
we don't have to be friends
but we can be allies
that's something i can get on board with
great yay
look at us go best friend simulator 2021
everybody's having a great time
fun adventures for all involved
all right this is where i'm gonna stop
man that was intense a lot just went
down a lot just went down
wow video games look at them continuing
to video games
uh the next episode of this will be up
in a couple of days i'm generally doing
like two day waits between them
and
yeah i imagine we probably only have one
or two more left i guess we'll find out